we've got an interesting voicemail that
came in yesterday two one nine two david
p is the number you can call any time of
day any time it strikes your fancy or
you get a tickle to get on the phone
with us you can call to 192 david p here
is a caller from yesterday hi david this
is Ken from Southern California been a
while since I called listened to all
those [ __ ] grabber supporters out there
Donald Trump supporters out there that
are wearing those hot rather be Russian
than a Democrat so maybe they said all
move to Russia and yeah
Syrians Vladimir Putin's government
first hand instead of bringing that kind
of thanks David Ken from Southern
California very very fired up yeah if
you haven't heard of this Trump recently
did another one of these campaign
rallies in I don't know if it was Ohio
or I can't even keep track he's doing
them all the time and there were
supporters of his wearing shirts that
said I'd rather be Russian than a
Democrat which we know right like we
know that there are a ton of Republicans
who would prefer to have a president who
is compromised by a hostile foreign
country than having a Democratic
president like that's no surprise it's
not even shocking there were some people
who reacted and said David those
t-shirts must be plants and not real
what do you mean it's not real they're
straight up telling us by how they act
with regard to the Trump Russia
investigation they would prefer a Russia
compromised Republican than a Democrat
in the White House I mean those shirts
don't really help Trump's case though
that he had nothing to do with Russia in
the 2016 elections they don't know it's
not really helping their leader right no
I don't know that it hurts that much
it's really more an indictment of the
people wearing the shirts but yeah it's
certainly not if I were Trump I I don't
want to see that around right on today's
bonus show we will talk about stephen
miller's uncle saying this guy is a
complete and total hypocrite and twelve
of our relatives agree we will talk
about the chaos and scandal at Tesla
with Elon Musk's very bizarre recent
tweets and will also talk about rising
gun violence in Canada two ways to get
access to the bonus show become a member
at WWJ impact muncom become a patron at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show I'll speak to
you then